la forêt française joue un rôle
essentiel dans la conservation de la
biodiversité et face aux enjeux
économiques environnementaux et
sociétaux que rencontrent les forêts de
France l'Office National des Forêts
organisent le 27 septembre prochain un
temps d'échange entre des spécialistes
et les publics alors ça se passera dans
80 forêts de manielles et régionale en
France dans les Yvelines 9 sites sont
concernés et pour en parler avec nous
Michel Béal bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes le directeur de l'agence
territoriale ONF Île-de-France ouest
alors tout d'abord est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer l'importance de ce
type de journée effectivement très
important pour nous avec 12 millions
d'habitants les Franciliens
s'intéressent à la forêt viennent en
forêt très souvent et par contre il la
connaissent mal il l'ignore et donc
souvent on a beaucoup de questions et on
s'est dit pourquoi pas une journée
dédiée à l'accueil du public et à la
sensibilisation des publics et donc on
pas pour les accueillir ce jour-là alors
justement cet après-midi comment est-ce
qu'elle se déroule et ce qu'il y a des
échanges des balades comment ça se passe
exactement on a fixé dans les grandes
forêts domaniale des Yvelines mais
également dans toute leur reste de la
région parisienne des lieux de rencontre
où il y aura sur ces lieux de rencontre
deux ou trois ou quatre personnes de
l'ONF les forestiers de terrain qui
connaissent bien la forêt mais également
ce jour-là il y aura les autres
personnes de l'ONF qui seront également
sur le terrain et ça sera sur ces lieux
de rencontres à 14h le mercredi 27
septembre que pourront venir tous les
habitants tous les riverains ceux qui
veulent et on parle dans cette journée
on parle de forêt domaniale mais aussi
de forêts régionales c'est quoi la
différence exactement tout à fait depuis
l'année dernière la région Île-de-France
qui est propriétaire de forêt est venu
se retrouver dans cette opération donc
ça va se passer à la fois dans les
forêts domaniales c'est celle qui
appartiennent à l'État c'est l'État qui
est propriétaire comme la forêt de
Rambouillet comme la forêt de
Fontainebleau la forêt de Saint-Germain
mais il y aura également des points de
rencontre avec les personnels de
Île-de-France nature qui gère les forêts
régionales comme la forêt de Ferrières
en Seine-et-Marne par exemple est-ce que
vous savez à peu près les types de
questions qui reviennent le plus souvent
puisque c'est la troisième édition que
vous organisez et quels sont les points
de difficultés ou de questionnements que
rencontrent les citoyens souvent le
citoyen qui vient en forêt il pense la
forêt comme un décor mais il voit pas
toujours
ce milieu naturel complexe mais aussi
gérer ces forêts sont entretenus sont
gérés si elles ont cette qualité
paysagère c'est parce qu'elles sont
gérées depuis cinq siècles six siècles
donc souvent les questions c'est ce que
j'appellerai des fois les du temps pour
le public pourquoi les coupes de bois à
quoi ça sert où est-ce que va le bois
pourquoi il y a de la chasse donc c'est
des questions de ce type là qui
reviennent le plus souvent et bien sûr
comme c'est notre métier on répond à
toutes alors est-ce qu'il y a aussi des
questions qui sont en rapport avec les
enjeux climatiques qu'on rencontre
aujourd'hui ou la coupe des arbres par
exemple tout à fait tout à fait c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui notamment dans les
Yvelines les certaines forêts souffrent
du changement climatique une essence en
particulier en souffre c'est le
châtaignier on a des châtaigniers autour
de nous certains châtaigniers sont
atteints d'une maladie maladie qui s'est
développée à cause du changement
climatique donc il y a grand nombre
notamment en forêt de Marly dans les
Yvelines des châtaigniers qui meurent
qui sont nécessairement coupés parce
qu'une fois qu'ils sont morts on n'a pas
d'autres
issues bien sûr après il y a des
replantations donc c'est ces questions
là qu'on pourra aborder le changement
climatique comment il se dans nos forêts
ici en Île-de-France les forestiers
seront là ce jour-là pour répondre à
toutes les questions et aux enfants qui
pourront venir puisqu'on est un mercredi
et justement face à ces questions
quelles sont les enjeux que rencontre
les forêts des Yvelines actuellement les
grands enjeux les grands enjeux
finalement on retrouve bien le triptyque
qu'on peut avoir dans l'ensemble des
forêts je dirais la particularité des de
l'Île-de-France et des Yvelines c'est
que les trois enjeux principaux sont
bien équilibrés en jeu de fréquentation
avec 10 millions d'habitants les forêts
les forêts d'Île-de-France sont sans
doute les plus fréquentées de France
avec évidemment pour répondre à la
demande sociale d'accueillir le public
en forêt
l'enjeu l'enjeu de biodiversité ces
forêts sont souvent riches d'une grande
réservoir de biodiversité avec des
espèces parfois rares parfois protégées
liés à la présence de
une vieille forêt de vieux arbres ou de
milieux humides la mission de l'ONF ici
en Île-de-France c'est de préserver
cette biodiversité et bien sûr à
quelques kilomètres de Paris la France
n'a jamais eu autant besoin de bois donc
entretenir la forêt ça passe aussi par
des coupes de bois et donc il y a
l'enjeu économique il est aussi
important dans notre région alors c'est
la troisième fois que l'événement
revient est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui rassemble vous attendez combien de
personnes à peu près l'année dernière à
l'échelle de l'Île-de-France était plus
de 1000 personnes qu'il y avait on
espère qu'il y en aura beaucoup plus
cette année en tout cas grâce à au
Relais des communes des collectivités
avec lequel nous travaillons
l'information a été largement passée et
on espère que beaucoup de Franciliens
viendront ce jour-là encore plus
nombreux que l'année dernière bien merci
si vous aussi vous souhaitez participer
à cet événement sachez qu'il est gratuit
ce sera le 27 septembre à 14h voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
Michel belle pour cette interview et en
attendant le 27 je vous souhaite de
passer une excellente soirée sur TV 78